foreign
comes from Alan in Ohio he writes I live
in an apartment but I'm looking to get a
home in the next year to year and a half
I work as a design engineer and
currently make 25 bucks an hour I've got
25 000 in student loan debt to the
government and I graduated in May of
2020. I want to know of any side hustles
that can help me pay off my student debt
and help me build a comfortable life for
a future family thanks for the question
Alan I love this question and when you
talk about somebody of Allen's uh
credibility or the word I'm looking for
is actually pedigree because he goes to
school and he gets an engineering degree
right and so Engineers can command
really good money not just in salary but
in freelance hourly rates and the
freelance economy is what it's being
labeled as right now uh the gig economy
is another term you hear it's just fancy
language for it's a side hustle it's
above and beyond my full-time job and
and professional White Collar skilled
jobs have more freelance opportunity
than ever before George because of this
weird economy we're in where we have
10.1 million jobs available but only 8
million people unemployed so companies
are also worried about recession and so
they've cut back so instead of hiring a
full-time employee they're looking for
contract a contractor and you've done
this work before and in his situation
where I would start the Practical advice
is his top two or three skills
is where he's looking as an engineer and
he's he's separating those and he's
going okay I'm really good at this this
and this and so now he's looking out
there where freelancing opportunities
because he brings credibility in that
degree and everyday experience and
that's where he's going to get the
biggest bang for the buck is actually
his professional skills now he can do
other things we're going to talk about
in a minute for everybody but you you've
done this
out you actually did this and I wanted
you to share this because you made
really good money using your existing
professional skills yes so first of all
I was willing to do anything and so I
was driving for Uber and Lyft and doing
some of the normal early adopter on that
I got some sign-on bonuses when they
first came to Nashville when Uber and
Lyft wow so they gave me like a thousand
bucks to do like three rides that was
great so it was a great side money but
beyond that I went I don't like driving
strangers around it's not something I
enjoy can I find the side gig I enjoy
doing that I'm good at that's when I
went I've got marketing skill and I
found this post I did Ken back in uh
this is 2019 I was trying to save up for
our download is this from your personal
blog this isn't my personal blog my
zanga page here's what it says if you
need help with social media email
marketing branding copywriting content
creation website creation podcasting
video audio production production
keynote presentations DM me for
Consulting work and I got some great
gigs helping small business owners
authors speakers build websites and
Squarespace I was making 1500 bucks a
website fifteen hundred bucks yeah and
were you using one of those uh the
website in a box Squarespace yeah that's
right so that was one I did marketing
Consulting back in uh when I was getting
rid of my Consumer Debt I think I made
23 Grand doing that part-time yeah
nights and weekends very doable all
right so let's let's also bring this
down to summer jobs for kids trying to
make money for college teachers too that
are single for the summer people are
trying to make extra money uh we've got
a an article that we did at
ramseysolutions.com we're not going to
go through all of these and I've got
some personal anecdotes some stories
here what I'm seeing uh young people do
that can be done quite frankly by
anybody uh but you mentioned Uber and
and Lyft let's just say delivering food
delivering groceries delivering people
to places is still a very very
accessible opportunity uh now I will say
this it comes with wear and tear on the
car I've interviewed some of these
drivers and I think George I've got to
weigh it you gotta weigh that like okay
the wear and tear Insurance all that
kind of stuff gas yes make sure that
you're covered contact your auto
insurance do not surprise them if you
get in a wreck while driving for one of
these apps you may not be covered yeah
don't say it and tell yourself uh okay
here we go here's some creative things
uh photographer uh tutoring uh in in any
type of uh topic there also online
teaching is an opportunity for a lot of
people the one that I love here on the
list and I'm seeing this is the
reselling people that are going to flea
market the flea market flipping that's
big you can really score uh and make
some really good money now you got to
know what you're doing yeah garage sales
yard sales flea markets even Goodwill
yeah buy stuff for cheap and look it up
on eBay see what it's selling for and go
clean it up and flip it uh the one that
I love sharing I share this on my Show
recently about a young lady who had just
graduated uh from law school and she was
looking to get on with a firm and uh
wasn't finding what she wanted she's
trying to figure it out and she stumbles
into uh someone who says I've got some
friends who want someone to walk their
dogs they've got three dogs and she says
well what do they pay and it's really
you know it's pretty good in New York
Manhattan okay it's big money there so
she starts doing it and she realized
like like this is really good money for
my time she now makes over a hundred
thirty thousand dollars a year in
Manhattan with a dog walking service to
where now she's got so many clients that
she Farms it out if you will to other
people but she's clearing over six
figures walking dogs that's amazing
which is well over 60 bucks an hour by
the way it's fantastic doing the math at
home all right here's a fun story George
uh my wife Stacy shared this story with
me of a young man in our neighborhood
right here in Franklin Tennessee who's
making several hundred dollars a week
are you ready for this yeah hit me power
washing this is a big one garbage cans a
power washer costs you can get them for
100 bucks yeah and so you got these
nasty stinking garbage cans I never even
thought about it and he's going around
he's power washed pressure washing these
uh garbage you can charge 15 20 bucks a
pop for these yeah and it takes you a
few minutes yeah here's another absurd
one and I say it's absurd that people
pay for this but folks we live in a
world where people have so much
disposable income all you got to do is
think about can I solve a problem now
this is absurd but this is my
neighborhood again this guy's 55 years
of age he's retired but he does this
just for fun and he's making a really
good he's making over five thousand
dollars a month you ready for this
picking up glass bottles what and
recycling them for people they just put
them out there they don't want to they
don't want to get rid of them they think
they should recycle but they don't want
to deal with it and he goes around and
picks them up and he's charging people
very handsomely they have several
hundred homes where he's picking up I
know where you live Ken I may roll
around that neighborhood and pick up
some glass who's throwing money out like
that's wild is that not absurd it's a
great side hustle I saw one in my
neighborhood painting mailboxes your
mailbox gets a little weathered a little
worn we'll repaint the mailbox so you
can get so creative and let me tell you
dog walking and pet sitting one of the
most lucrative things out there you can
charge 25 30 bucks an hour one of my
kids one of my kids is going to make a
thousand dollars over eight to ten days
dog sitting another golden doodle who
looks just like our dog Ellis you know
what I did the other day got my car my
house James he's looking at me like I'm
nuts I'm not kidding you 10 days we're
watching this dog thousand bucks that's
insane that's the market rate I might do
it you might maybe I'm open to it but
this is another one can mobile car
detailing show up in someone's driveway
big bucks use their water spigot oh you
clean their car I just I paid a guy to
do this last weekend he did my car he
did such a great job I said come back
tomorrow do my wife says UV what'd you
try I think it was a hundred bucks
and maybe 125 for an SUV so in a few
hours he made 100 bucks another few
hours another 125 bucks and he can do
three four of these a day wow
that's some serious money yeah so get
creative and the more you're willing to
put effort in the more money you're
gonna make if you want to sit at home
and take little surveys on your phone
you're not going to make good money so
so why do we spend time on this
because there are a lot of people that
are constantly coming into our
atmosphere watching the show listening
to the show and they feel like getting a
thousand dollars in baby step one is
almost impossible the wages can that's
the problem and the fact is is folks
it's never been easier to make a
thousand dollars in quick time frames to
be able to get that baby step one funded
and then quite frankly keep that
momentum going and walk through baby
step two so you can do it it's very
important all kinds of options by the
way if you want to dive in deeper that
article
ramsaysolutions dot we're going to link
it in the show notes in the description
very nice thank you George for all the
podcasters it's 27 side hustle ideas
ramsesolutions.com